And I think that's part of the reason
why human beings can be so infinitely
creative,
right?
For us,
the world isn't fixed.
We never know what it's
going to bring forth.
So 100 years ago,
if someone would have said,
well,
you could build a machine on a wafer,
a centimeter square out of sand,
and if you have enough of those machines,
than everyone in the
world can be connected.
And everyone in the world can have an
infinite library of verbal material,
right?
That's impossible.
But it's not impossible.
It turns out that Silica has those
properties and we can build unbelievably
powerful machines out of nothing.
And so then that kind of makes
you think about just what this.
Nothing that we're building
things out of his right,
because it seems to be able to reveal
a constant array of properties.
Properties that are essentially unlimited
and its capacity to reveal those
properties seems to depend as much
on our ability to interact with it.
Whatever that is,
as it does on whatever the stuff is.
And we know even from a strict object
perception of the world that the stuff
that things are made of is a lot more
complicated than we had originally
presumed,
even as materialists because
materialists realists,
there are philosophy only holds down to
about the subatomic level of analysis.
Deterministic worldview below
the subatomic level of analysis.
There's nothing deterministic at all and
the stuff that things are made of is so
mysterious that we can't even.
We can't grasp,
but we can't comprehend it.
So it turns out that rather than the
story world be being dependent on the
object world,
it might be the other way around.
The object world is dependent on the
story world and that implies at least to
some degree that the story
world is actually more real.
Whatever that means.
And then I told you that,
well,
the real problem of life isn't so much
what do you do when you're around things
that you understand?
The real problem of life is what do
you do when you encounter something you
can't conceptualize?
And I think a good recent example of
that was the bombing of the world trade
towers,
which people were compelled to watch
over and over and over and over.
And if you ask someone,
well what is it that you're watching?
They would say,
well,
I'm watching the world
trade towers fall down,
but then you might say,
well why are you watching
it over and over?
And they would say something like,
well,
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it's happening.
And what does that mean?
It means something like whatever
it is that's happening here,
whatever's being blown apart
exceeds my ability to model.
And as a consequence I have to expose
myself to it again and again and again and
again to try to understand what's falling,
what's falling exactly.
Is it just the.
Is it just the Towers is at 20,000 people?
Is that the financial system of the u?
S is the stability of the Western world
is at the beginning of world war three
or as the former CIA director
just mentioned in the u,
the beginning of World War for what
is it exactly that you're looking at?
When something happens
that you don't understand
and then you'll say,
well,
how do you react to that?
And it turns out that you
react mostly with your body,
not with your mind,
not with your perceptual systems,
not with your thoughts,
but with your emotions and your body,
and that means you sweat and you panic
and you feel depressed and you feel hurt
and you feel ashamed and you're prepared
for a catastrophe which is stress and
all that basically noncognitive.
And what that means is that when you
encounter something you don't understand,
the first manner in which you
conceive of it is embodied emotional,
physical way.
Before you develop up an
object representation or
cognitive representation,
you may not ever get it like an event
like that or a worse event can throw
someone into a tailspin that's so
extreme that they never get out of it.
So you see,
for example,
sometimes,
and this is more true
among elderly people,
if their spouse dies,
the probability that they'll
die in the next year,
say from a heart attack
or something like that,
increases substantially.
Why is that?
It's because they're conceptual frame was
so dependent on the existence of their
spouse.
Say someone they've lived with for 25
years that the anxiety and uncertainty
caused by their anomalous disappearance
there death is so extreme that it sends
their body into a physiological state
that's basically unbearable and that does
the men,
and when you start to understand what
having your preconceptions rattled really
means,
then you also start to understand why
people are so motivated to protect their
ideological territory,
right?
Because ideological territory,
that's how you see the world.
That's your story and you can't have
your fundaments rattled all the time
because it throws everything into chaos
and that puts you in this terrible,
panicky cortisol written stressful state
that's really hard on you physically.
So we know,
for example,
that if you're in a state where you're
chronically exposed to threat or
punishment,
which is the case in depression,
say you produce a lot of cortisol,
which is a stress hormone
and cortisol is toxic,
so the more of it you produce,
the more you kill off your hippocampal
cells and you really need them because
they are key to memory.
You do in your immunological system.
There's all sorts of negative side
effects of cortisol poisoning,
increased incidents of
cardiovascular disease,
heightened grade IV cancer,
plus it's just no fun,
right?
It's the worst thing that can
possibly happen to you essentially.
If something I know it happens to
you in blows your frame of reference,
right,
knocks you for a loop,
sends you to the underworld,
however you want to construe it,
that's really going to upset
your bandwagon and throw
you into a state that you
do virtually anything to avoid.
But by the same token,
there is a possibility that
inside that chaotic mess,
there's something you really need.
And what's the logic there?
Well,
the logic is something like this.
When you look at the world,
you only see a fragment of it and that's
good because it's pretty overwhelming
and a fragments generally
more than enough,
but all the information that you've ever
gathered in your entire life to build
yourself out of and to make your life
stable has come as a consequence of your
ability to explore what
you don't understand,
and that's an unlimited capacity,
right?
No matter how much you explored,
how much information you gather,
there's always the possibility that
there's way more information out there and
that means if you have a problem
and you see that it's a problem,
even though that's frightening,
it's also a gateway into a domain of
possibility and the possibility is this
richly informative background that
could in principle provide you with any
answer you need and then
you can take one more thing.
And the old Gods,
Mars say the God of war,
Venus,
the god of love,
they're all internalized for us,
right?
We know that anger is the psychological
state and that love is the psychological
state,
but if we look at our
great religious traditions,
Christianity say or Buddhism,
just to take two as an example,
we still have this notion that what
these figures represent is something
external.
Well,
you might say how primitive,
right?
Just as primitive as the idea that
the god of war is something external,
is the idea that this sort of figure,
it's supposed to be something external.
It's supposed to be something embodied,
right?
It's a story about the nature of
individual moral responsibility.
So the idea is something like this,
well,
reality itself,
the existence of things seems to depend
on the existence of a finite observer so
that we can see things from a perspective.
If you don't see things
from a perspective,
everything is the same.
There's nothing delineated,
but if there's going to
be delineated things,
small things,
insufficient things,
and they're going to be aware they're
going to be vulnerable as a part of their
limitation.
And so you say,
well,
limitation is a precondition for being
and that means suffering is part and
parcel of being.
Dostoevsky.
Said clearly,
look,
I give you all the cake you want,
you got a big house,
you got nothing to do,
but watch TV,
right?
And propagate the species.
Are you happy?
And Dostoevsky says,
well,
no.
Why?
Well,
because human beings are
really fundamentally,
you're ungrateful and insane.
So if you give them some
little comfortable niche to
occupy themselves with so
they don't have anything to worry about.
The first thing they're gonna do,
just like Adam and eve basically
are just like Gautama Buddha.
They're going to run around
looking for the apple,
looking for the snake,
looking for the trouble to
smash the frame into bits,
no matter how comfortable it is,
just so they can get access
to little and have some fun.
And so then you think,
well maybe it's more like the purpose
of life isn't to avoid chaos because we
like chaos.
It's entertaining,
right?
It keeps us alert and awake and it gives
us something to do that really has no
end.
And so maybe the answer
is something more like,
well,
forget the frame of reference,
forget the chaos,
but hit the balance right between the two.
Right?
So that you've got one foot where it's
reasonably comfortable and you got one
foot out there where it's kind of
exciting and dangerous and that's perfect,
and then you think the state you want to
attain that makes you resistant to even
the greatest anomalies.
Anomalies of death,
say,
or vulnerability or mortality is exactly.
That's that position,
right balance straight between the forces
of chaos and the forces of order or
between Yin and Yang and how do you
know you're there because that's what it
really boils down to.
How do you know that you're
there and then you think,
okay,
it's pretty simple.
You Watch with your eyes open,
just like Solzhenitsyn Watch.
Do you think I don't know everything,
so let's see what I do.
No,
no preconceptions.
I'm not going to shield myself from the
truth with some second rate frame of
reference.
We don't believe in those anyways
because they're always fragmental.
I'm just going to watch.
So when am I not miserable?
And then you think,
wow,
I'm not miserable when
I'm interested in things.
Something I get interested in,
something I don't exactly know
why I get interested in it.
It catches me.
What are the,
what's the phenomenology of being caught,
are not self conscious.
When I'm engaged in something,
I'm more like a child,
which is why children have
intimations of immortality.
I mean engaged in this process.
I don't think about myself,
so I'm not self conscious.
I lose my sense of temporality because
it seems like I can do whatever it is
that I'm doing thing that I enjoy for
hours and the time flies by and I'm not
even really aware of the surrounding
world and none of my existential concerns
are paramount at that time.
Every need is suppressed by
my engagement in the activity.
And then you say to yourself,
well,
yeah,
I find that only happens like you know,
10 minutes every three days or something
when I'm being particularly miserable.
But you might say,
well,
the fact that it happens at all is
probably worth paying attention to.
I mean if you believe that
your experience is real,
like real,
the fact that you can get
into a state like that at all,
it's worth paying attention to.
And so then you might say,
well that's,
that's where your sense of ethics
really starts to arise is what makes you
interested.
Well,
it might be just as cracked and,
and,
and peculiar as something
you could possibly imagine,
right?
Your parents are against it,
your friends or against it.
Even you're against it when
you're thinking clearly,
but there's still this reality that
something compels you and then you think,
well,
can you trust it?
And I think,
well that's a tough question because
I read a long time for a long time,
I read accounts of serial killers
because I was really interested in what
motivated.
Right?
And they're an interesting
breed in many ways,
which is why there's such a
popular fascination with them.
And so then you think about a
story like that and you think,
Geez,
maybe you can't trust your interest,
right?
Maybe it'll take you somewhere.
You don't want to go,
like seriously where you don't want to go.
How do you know that if you really
let yourself be who you could be,
that you'd end up somewhere good.
And so then you come to the
second part of the story,
which is something like this.
Let's say that you're a very,
very,
very finely tuned biological machine,
right?
Lack into a computer and then you say,
okay,
you take a computer and you
feed it false information.
What do you get out?
False information,
right?
Well,
you've stuck with this computer.
It's very complicated.
You kind of reside in it in some
manner you don't understand.
And yet you're prone pawn occasions
either to deny it information altogether
when you walk away from something you
know you shouldn't walk away from or to
it,
bad information.
And so then what if,
what if this was the case?
What if it was the case that the systems
that Orient you with regards to your
interest can become pathologized by
any relationship you have with yourself
that's predicated on bad faith.
And so then you think,
well,
that's why there's an ethical
aspect to this redemptive process.
Like a real strenuous and
strict ethical aspect.
It goes something like this.
There are things that you can do.
Find yourself engaged with the world
at such a level that your existential
concerns could disappear and we can even
understand that biochemically to some
degree because if you're
really interested in something,
you get a dopamine release,
an exploratory dopamine release,
that's great.
I mean that's associated with
positive effect with confidence,
with increased immunological functioning,
with better memory functioning
with learning everything you want.
It's also potently antianxiety,
lytic and analgesic,
which means that if you're really pursuing
something that's compelling to you,
you're much more resistant
biochemically to punishment,
disappointment,
depression,
pain,
threat,
et Cetera,
and it's not because you're blind,
you're blind.
It's because your nervous system is
optimally tuned to make you maximally
resistant,
and so then you might think
if you were optimally tuned,
how resistant would you be?
You don't know,
right?
Because it's a spiral that
never stops moving uphill.
We don't know what the upper mds and we
have exemplars that might indicate what
that upper end could be,
but we don't actually know.
So then you think,
okay,
well here's the.
Here's the rule.
Say something like this.
If you look at the world
from this perspective,
which is something you
have to decide if you're,
you know,
you find compelling and reasonable.
The rule is this,
you're always gonna run into it normally,
right?
And,
uh,
normally is always going to
look to look to you like,
like this,
and it's no bloody wonder.
You want to run away from that.
I mean in some ways is your whole body's
telling you watch out and for good
reason because it's no joke,
but then it was more to the story
because the anomalous thing,
that's everything you don't know.
And you might say,
well,
you're going out with someone and you
want to have a longterm relationship.
They'd be true.
How could there be any good in that?
Because that's certainly what you're
going to ask when you first encounter the
unexpected information,
but then you might think could be that
I'm a little too naive for my own good,
right?
People pull me in a little more than they
should or I'm not sufficiently careful
when I enter into intimate relationships
with people or I don't treat people
right or I don't have a
good conceptualization of
myself or I'm chasing after
the wrong person.
Well,
that's all going to be
very annoying to learn,
but if you don't learn it,
you're going to be in big trouble.
So maybe the best thing to do and enormity
of that sort hits you is to think,
okay,
yeah,
it's a dragon.
No doubt it will eat me,
but if I don't let it eat me,
then they'll just be another one waiting
around the corner and it'll probably be
a little bit bigger and if I
get eaten by enough of them,
I'm not really gonna want to be around
much and maybe I'm not going to be
willing to help other people
be around much either.
It doesn't seem like a very
good alternative to me.
Back in 1957,
some new gnostic writings were
discovered in a and a cave.
They were discovered by these two Arab
guys who went out to kill the man who
killed her father.
They took them out into this cave.
Then they killed them and
when they were burying them,
they found exam for a full of papers
and papyrus and they took them home and
their mother used a bunch of them too,
like cooking fires with and one day one
of their friends who was an antiquities
dealer showed up and he said,
you know,
you shouldn't be burning those.
Those are about 1500 years old and they
look like very early gnostic gospels and
the Gnostics were this branch of
Christianity that was pretty violently
suppressed by the emergence of Orthodox
Christianity and the gnostics believed
that faith was a good thing,
but knowledge was all right too.
And they wrote Gospel accounts say
of Christ's life that were knowledge
predicated as much as
revelation predicated.
Say,
and this is one of the quotes
from one of those Gospels,
the Gospel of Thomas,
which is actually one that
the only one that got out,
Carl young got ahold of them.
Interestingly enough,
and this is one of the quotes
and I really liked this,
this is a non canonical saying
of Christ and the saying is,
if you bring forth what is within you,
why don't you bring forth will save you.
If you do not bring
forth what is within you,
what you do not bring
forth will destroy you,
and I think that's a pretty good
line to close off the class.